hey everybody i'm off the grid for
august but the biden administration
still sucks
why is it that over the last couple
months president biden has been so much
tougher on russia than he is on china
i wouldn't agree with the premise of the
question uh peter well i think just
when russia was getting aggressive
around ukraine the president was out
every couple days telling putin don't
do it and now china is getting
aggressive around taiwan and we're not
hearing anything like that from the
president oh i beg to differ we've been
standing up here for almost a week peter
talking about
our concerns about
what china was preparing to do we put
out
uh declassified information that we saw
what the chinese playbook was going to
be
look i stood at another podium uh
a lot long ago and much of the same way
we we reacted then we're reacting now in
terms of being honest and transparent
about what's going on and calling it out
for what it is um and then today talking
about exactly what we're going to do to
make sure we can help preserve a free
and open indo-pacific so i'm afraid i
just challenge the premise of your
question i know you said that there is
not as a
call scheduled with she is there a
reason why because president biden's
known him for
decades
he's got a lot of free time up there in
the residence this week he doesn't have
free time
he's
been working all the way through his
illness quite frankly peter so that's a
little bit insulting and um as for a
call
it is it is
that someone who is isolating by himself
you suggested he has a lot of free time
as if he's not doing anything and you
know that's not the case mr ducey now
look as for a call with president xi i
don't have anything on the president's
schedule to speak to if ever the
president felt like a call with
president xi was the appropriate way to
respond or that it would uh that it
would have an effect and an outcome that
he wants to achieve he certainly would
be willing to do that he's talked to
she now five times it's not like he's
afraid to pick up the phone and call uh
president xi and if there's a
if a call is the right answer
i'm sure that president biden will do
that but i'm not going to get ahead of
the president on this